[Música]
eeuu registra el mayor número de
fallecidos por sobredosis de droga de su
historia más de 100 mil estadounidenses
murieron por sobredosis de drogas en un
año durante la pandemia de kobe 19 los
datos fueron dados a conocer por los
centros para el control y la prevención
de enfermedades los fallecimientos
aumentaron un 28.5 por ciento en los 12
meses que terminaron en abril pasado
según expertos las sobredosis
probablemente aumentaron debido al costo
psicológico de la pandemia además la
disponibilidad de más opioides
sintéticos como el fentanilo para ello
quiero darle la bienvenida a mi guel
bettini desde director de la fundación
crecer magister en drogodependencias de
la universidad de barcelona gracias a
miguel por estar aquí con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 y quiero
preguntar entonces la primera pregunta
para entrar en contexto que son las
drogas sintéticas los opioides
bueno los opioides son todos los
derivados de la planta conocida como
dormidera y hay un número de
medicamentos importantes en que tienen
todas las características propias de la
adormidera de los opioides surgidos de
ahí que también es tienen participación
de elementos extraordinarios
químicos y por lo tanto ya no son
totalmente puros sino sintéticos de esos
hay una gran
una gran cantidad de ellos precisamente
como el fentanilo el oxycontin y el tram
al que son medicamentos de un uso
desafortunadamente muy amplio e
irresponsable entonces son medicamentos
que tienen un alto nivel de sedación y
que obviamente también ayudan mucho para
el dolor pero que se están usando desde
hace un tiempo para acá de forma
irresponsable no sólo por los pacientes
sino también por médicos que no son
conocedores
y amplios de el riesgo que se corre por
el uso
irresponsable de este tipo de
medicamentos ahora miguel entendiendo ya
que son estas drogas sintéticas los
opioides como la pandemia de coronavirus
se incrementó este consumo se puede
decir además que en eeuu hay una
epidemia de opioides
indudablemente que si hay una epidemia
de enorme epidemia que no surgió con la
epidemia de la obediente es una epidemia
que venía ya desde los años 2010 hacia
está pero que indudablemente se ha
incrementado muchísimo con los fenómenos
de ansiedad y de depresión sobre todo
que ha traído consigo la epidemia de la
cob y 19
pero como digo esta epidemia ya venía
andando muy fuertemente en eeuu y no
sólo en eeuu sino en todo el en todo el
mundo pero muy especialmente claro que
si en los eeuu y ha estado muy bien
documentada en muchos textos en muchos
artículos científicos en revistas
indexadas
en el texto tierra de sueños de sanquín
o en ese es un texto muy interesante que
describe no solamente el fenómeno desde
el punto de vista médico sino todas las
implicaciones económicas y políticas que
hay detrás de este fenómeno de la
epidemia con opioides uopj así es como
también se les denomina y precisamente
ese tema lo quería tocar está ligado a
este aumento del consumo de opio 10
también de los problemas sociales y
económicos de muchos mayores de los que
poco también se habla estos problemas
sociales
y otro otro gran otro gran científico
norteamericano el doctor de hito aunque
además el premio nobel de economía
acaba de sacar un texto hace unos dos
años que denomina muertes por
desesperación en los eeuu y él considera
que las tres los tres tipos de muertes
por desesperación que hay en los eeuu en
este momento es el suicidio el abuso de
sustancias dentro de los dentro de las
cuales está principalísima mente el
abuso de opioides por estos actores que
señalaba hace un momento y las
consecuencias del alcoholismo la
cirrosis la accidentalidad etcétera y
eso que denomina muerte por
desesperación están bien ligados a
fenómenos económicos y políticos en los
eeuu antes se consideraba por ejemplo el
suicidio desde que se empezó a hablar de
él muy ligado a clases altas y agentes
agentes con altos niveles de formación
pues hoy no hoy lo que se está viendo es
que son las clases medias de pronto
menos educadas con este tipo de muertes
por desesperación como así las llama las
llamadas entonces que cuando hablemos de
suicidio hablemos de drogas más que
pensar en el individuo tenemos que
pensar en la sociedad que está detrás y
que idealmente está estimulando la
aparición de este tipo de fenómenos por
descuido o porque hay intereses
económicos y políticos que de alguna era
que descuidan esto no olvidemos que las
grandes compañías productoras por
ejemplo el de los chicos tiene del
oxycontin en la familia sackler en los
eeuu y que obviamente cotiza en bolsa se
ha demostrado unos grandísimos ingresos
por eso significa que el oxycontin y los
opioides per ccama los ayudan muchísimo
lo que está obviamente haciéndose mal es
la prescripción e irresponsable por
parte de profesionales de salud en uno y
una ausencia de políticas preventivas
para ella
ahora doctor también quería preguntarle
digamos está esta epidemia de los obvios
y en eeuu reventó durante la presidencia
de donald trump no entonces le quiero
preguntar él dijo anunció una lucha
contra los opio 10 fracasó en esta lucha
y exhibiendo este fracaso digamos que
otras opciones tienen las autoridades
estadounidenses y las autoridades del
mundo para prevenir que estos opioides
se vendan en el mercado ilegal de drogas
para un uso para un uso para un mal uso
yo creo que uno se viene hablando
últimamente mucho el fracaso de la lucha
contra las drogas y la palabra ha hecho
mella en las mentes de todos los seres
humanos pero también tenemos que tener
en cuenta que no podemos desconectar
unas drogas de otras hoy en día por
ejemplo hay lo que se conoce como una
disminución en la percepción del riesgo
en el uso de drogas por parte de niños y
jóvenes y eso aparentemente se está
debiendo a que estamos hablando de unas
bondades falsas de unas bondades
exageradas de alguna droga y se está
pidiendo el uso recreativo de ese tipo
de sustancias sin considerar el tipo de
riesgos que conllevan para niños y
jóvenes y eso se generaliza cuando un
niño un joven voy a hablar
recurrentemente de que de que las
sustancias en vez de ser sustancias que
le pueden ocasionar daños que son y no
pues realmente terminan siendo
sustancias que son inocuas y que
terminan haciéndole mucho bien pues los
niños y jóvenes generaliza en ese tipo
de precisión a todos los a todas las
sustancias que antes han sido de alguna
a proscritas yo creo que se trata de
llevar un discurso científico se trata
de llevar un discurso preventivo si a
eso le queremos llamar lucha pues les
llamaremos lucha pero lo que no podemos
es desistir de hacer prevención los
estados no pueden claudicar frente a un
fenómeno que ocasiona las muertes de
tantas personas las personas que llegan
a usar opioides que obviamente tienen
una gran posibilidad de letalidad como
también el alcohol que tiene una
grandísima posibilidad letalidad
empiezan por drogas que tienen menor
letalidad pero que no por ello dejan de
ocasionar ocasionar sufrimiento psíquico
desafortunamente en drogas se habla
mucho de sí ocasionan o no la muerte y
eso es un factor bien importante y se
habla poco de si las drogas crean o no
sufrimiento y dolor psicológico eso
también es un factor importante porque
el sufrimiento y el dolor psicológico
para un niño joven un anciano y una
familia es una cosa muy importante sobre
la cual debemos luchar si se quiere o
hacer políticas de prevención muy serias